they say you've got to spend money to
make money and plenty of major movies
have translated huge budgets into even
greater returns but sometimes pricey
high-profile projects just don't pay off
here's a look at some big-budget films
that were almost totally rejected by
North American audiences cutthroat
island making a pirate movie that looks
good is always going to be expensive the
details don't come cheap and neither
does top talent for the sweeping 1995
pirate adventure cutthroat island
Carroll Co Pictures tapped Renny Harlin
a proven action director who just held
two hits die hard - and cliffhanger
Harlan's picked two Star Academy Award
winner Geena Davis who was also his wife
at the time
but Davis wasn't a proven action star in
pirate movies hadn't been successful in
Hollywood for decades this was pre
Pirates of the Caribbean after all the
films 98 million dollar budget was put
to good use but critics pounced on the
movie in the public state away in droves
Carol ko was already pushed so far into
the red that the company filed for
bankruptcy in 1995 cutthroat island's
paltry 10 million dollar box office take
following its release a month later
didn't help town and country it was
supposed to be just a standard romantic
comedy aimed at an older upscale
audience yet it took three years in the
budget of a summer sci-fi blockbuster to
get Town and Country to theaters
Warren Beatty stars as a wealthy
philandering architect married for 25
years to an interior designer played by
Diane Keaton the couple's friends played
by Garry Shandling and Goldie Hawn are
caught up in their own infidelity mess
and further relationship hijinks ensue
when the action switches from town to
country the film's projected budget of
44 million included 10 million for
Beatty who reportedly was such a
perfectionist that his demand for
endless retakes stretched out the film's
shoot four years several of the film
stars also weren't happy with the
screenplay and brought in their own
script doctors to punch it up while the
movie was in production total final cost
of Town & Country 90 million dollars
total domestic box-office take of Town &
Country upon its release in spring 2001
just under 7 million dollars revolution
on paper it sounds like an undeniable
hit Hugh Hudson coming off the
back-to-back critical and commercial
hits Chariots of Fire and grey stroke
directed this epic revolutionary war
movie is told through the eyes of Tom
Dobb a reluctant to fight New York state
fur trapper played by Al Pacino oddly
enough this movie about the American
fight for freedom was produced by a
British studio and filmed in the English
countryside still 28 million was poured
into revolution making it one of the
most expensive movies of 1985 up there
with Rambo First Blood Part 2 but
revolution was a massive box-office flop
it earned just over $350,000 in the US
The Adventures of Pluto Nash sometimes
mixing two genres works wonders lethal
weapons action comedy hybrid being a
classic example but how about combining
gangster movie science fiction and
comedy not
so much sent me your 2080 The Adventures
of Pluto Nash starred Eddie Murphy as an
ex Mugler who gets out of prison and
buys a mob-connected nightclub on the
moon using some lunar States of America
cash why should take these Hillary's we
appreciate you helping us out the
screenplay bounced around Hollywood for
more than a decade before finally being
produced in 2000 and then it sat on the
Shelf Warner Brothers finally released
it late in the summer of 2002 only to
see it pull in just 4.4 million at the
domestic box office which didn't even
touch the film staggering 100 million
dollar budget
lucky you the mid-2000s poker craze
began a few poker movies such as this
2007 drama about a second generation
card shark looking to compete in the
World Series of Poker lucky you boasted
an impressive lineup and was directed by
Academy Award nominee Curtis Hanson who
co-wrote the script with Academy Award
winner Eric Roth perhaps it was the
level of top-notch talent that ran the
budget of this low-key movie up to
approximately 55 million but that roster
didn't attract big audiences lucky you
pulled in just 5.7 million at the
domestic box office it was a lukewarm
reception that certainly wasn't helped
by the negative reviews from critics
like Rex Reed of the New York Observer
who argued that it doesn't have enough
energy to keep the most catatonic
tournament poker addict awake monkey
bone well it's certainly original monkey
bone is about a cartoonist played by
Brendan Fraser who while in a coma
travels to a dark fantasy land called
downtown there he must defeat both death
incarnate and monkey bone and evil
cartoon monkey of his own creation
mixing live-action and animation is a
technically demanding and expensive task
and director Henry Selick
best known for the Nightmare Before
Christmas ran up a tab of 75 million
executives relieve Selleck of his
directorial duties after a terrible test
screening calling for a brand new cut of
the movie then executive producer Chris
Columbus oversaw another edit to make it
more palatable all the while the release
date was changed so often that the
studio only had two weeks before its
March 2001 opening to mount an
advertising campaign the end result for
monkey bone domestic revenues of just
over five million
Geely it's a punch line in film history
synonymous with flop and for good reason
for starters 2003 SG Lee has a title
that isn't immediately pronounceable
and a plot that falls somewhere between
nonsensical and offensive Ben Affleck
plays a thug
by his criminal bosses to intimidate a
federal prosecutor by kidnapping her
developmentally disabled brother things
don't go as planned so they send in
Jennifer Lopez another gangster to help
him
Affleck winds up falling in love with
her but it turns out that she's gay
nothing about Gigli seemed terribly
promising on paper but it extra
attention when it stars wound up in a
tabloid reti relationship ultimately
amplifying the negative pre-release buzz
when it arrived in theaters in August
2003 critics destroyed it against a
reported 54 million dollar budget the
film took in a hair over 6 million and
was pulled from theaters after just
three weeks this deprived many film
goers the opportunity to hear
Christopher Walken praised Marie
Callender's as only he can put some on
your head your tongue could slap your
brains out trying to get to it and now
you've witnessed the only good thing to
have come out of Gigli you're welcome
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]